exactly like my new hairstyle
okay this is new nervous hey I'm the new
sexy animal and in honor of Adam's
ridiculous bro-tastic hairdo we're gonna
do a nerd Wars WTF edition a lot of you
guys have put some nerd wars that are
just WT yeah so we're gonna start off
this one came from family clock it's
Dora the Explorer vs. Justin Bieber and
in his comic put a question mark after
Explorer so I'm not sure if he's unclear
whether she's Explorer or whether it's
did I get her maybe she's Dora the
ignore who knows okay so I'm gonna take
Dora you're gonna take Justin Bieber go
well I win done okay
Justin Beaver number one only has one
super power to attract prepubescent
girls and here's my daughter Dora the
Explorer would be sucked into his web
door would just be like what's up Justin
shank done and a discussion okay next
one next one we're gonna do me James er
me Jake I don't know mayhem user
whatever Darth Vader ooh pretty epic
versus Captain Kirk sorry Slater have to
go with Captain Kirk of course Captain
Kirk would kick Darth Vader's ass I'm
going to beat you Vader Scotty stop him
from choking me bad Kirk impression
Spock what should I do
okay the next one wait let's talk about
let's talk about Darth Vader we get
these quick what I want to hear long and
then what the alright I don't know do
you
I'll regardless we're doing it this way
you can put it in the comments the next
one Jack McGuire 24 posted a world of
warcraft level 80 paladin vs dr.
Manhattan BAM this is an easy one yeah
dr. Manhattan would dominate and why
because one look at that giant penis and
your average World of Warcraft player
would go right offline he wasn't saying
the player that was saying the paladin
yeah the paladin it would be right and
I'll only way the paladin
gonna win this fight is if he makes dr.
Manhattan so bored by farming freakin
rugged leather that dr. Manhattan just
kills himself yeah or causes himself to
cease to exist yeah that would be the
only way to be able to do it yeah
otherwise I don't know what you were on
when you wrote this if you have any more
send it our way we did we love him we do
love it but dr. Manhattan's kind of a
god and he is hung like a donkey
banjo gate sent us Unicron from the
Transformers versus Galactus for those
of you don't know Unicron is a
planet-sized transformer well he is a
planet he's a planet that's a
transformer and he forms from a planet
to a plane landed face yeah
whereas Galactus is you might not know
his surname eater of worlds yep okay
next his fears of F wave we got one more
the Ninja Turtles versus pizza I'm gonna
here we go with the pizza they're gonna
at the end of the day they're gonna eat
the pizza and diarrhea definitely
Unicron Unicron in the pizza okay tears
of absolution has the Foot Clan from
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
vs. the hand from Marvel now I think one
thing on the surface it seems like all
right they're two groups of Ninja
Assassin II kind of guys but the foot is
made up of robotic Androids the foot is
made up of robotic androids
that blow up when hit with a stick yeah
once you know Michelangelo started just
using a rope at the end he still blew up
the the foot soldiers got to give it to
the hand and it's a they yeah they're
organic what do you want we're gonna
have to give it to bio organism's until
machine until we hit the time of like
maybe terminator yeah then we'll give it
to the robot around 2015 okay John Mar
he's such a conspiracy yeah
John Mar this I think is the best WTF of
the whole list wo Pac Man vs. Captain
America yeah clearly
and she'll pair dead pacman would win
what
well Captain America's from the 1940s he
couldn't even figure out how to use
pac-man the technologies too advanced
for him
pac-man wins and I'm gonna have to say
somehow Captain America assisted through
all these other universes and did just
fine Adam stupid
okay next argument mogul is mogul Liz
2800 this is a final one peach versus
Zelda Princess Peach versus Princess
Zelda both heroines and videogames
heroines not really more damsels in
distress yeah just lazy jerks always
waitin this is usually what you get the
two of them together and they'd be like
well no hey if he can't link it well no
um I thought maybe Mario was gonna stop
by hmm you won't get raped by Bowser
all right well again it's already here
you sure you don't wanna yeah well let's
just sit in this dungeon let's do a
four-way mm-hmm seriously this isn't
even a fight yeah it that's a two-bit
fight if I've ever seen one huh I still
want to smack him very good anyway keep
posting them uh don't get offended if we
make fun of yours they're just stupid
yeah we're just happy Oh fun we're just
having fun but we do like your
suggestions you should tell them even
with your bad suggestions it does get us
talking for like hours on end it's true
so please keep sending them because we
have nothing to say to each other
anymore
yeah it's true what hasn't been said
about I'm being fed and just bawled
you